what's going on guys
today is going to be a strange episode
cuz we're talking about Doctor Strange
you know everybody is talking about
Captain America's Civil War we've talked
it to death but you know we haven't
explored as much dr. strange there are
new images coming out this is the other
Marvel film coming out this year and
we're gonna get into it with please
explain Doctor Strange and we have two
of the biggest strange heads in the
known universe first Oh welcome back the
producer of fat man on Batman one of the
co-hosts of Marvel movie news and a
contributing writer to geek girl
Authority calm Maki and this guy also
knows a thing or two about a thing or
two he's a writer in a podcaster and
just a big comic book fan sax car
let's talk Doctor Strange before we get
too far down the rabbit hole let's pull
back a little bit um talk to me about
his origin story he was introduced in
strange tales and he is Doctor Strange
so this was in the 60s right yes it was
he at 63 I think strange tells one time
and so but yeah he was a doctor and he
was a neurosurgeon yeah but he was a
surgeon and kind of a jerk and he was
like really just that you know at the
top of his craft and he gets in a car
accident and he ruins his hands and so
he can't work anymore and of course he
can't live with himself
yes he's perfect of being a surgeon he
expends all of his resources like he
goes through every last dollar trying to
find fixes for his the nerve damage in
his hands and finally ends up in like
India area where he hears of the ancient
one and how he can heal anything and he
goes out in search of this ancient one
and essentially eventually figures out
that he can do magic that magic is real
the ancient one apparently has had his
eye on him for a while ancient one is
currently like The Sorcerer's supreme
which is like a regular source is not a
Taco Bell okay good how much of this do
you think will delve into in the film
probably all of it yeah although you
know Marvel has in the movies been sort
of trying to avoid magic being magic
like magic is high science Thor has been
saying you know like oh it you think
it's magic but it's just our advanced
Asgardian technology this may be the
first one where it's really magic yeah
so I wanted open to its place in the MCU
in a moment but I want to know just a
little bit more about Doctor Strange
first does he have a nemesis uh he's got
a couple his biggest nemesis is Baron
Mordo who was being played by Xu
tell easier for yes they look like
they're best friends so my guess is that
Baron Mordo actually ends up being sort
of like the senior to dr. strangers
freshman or he's like come on buddy let
me show you kind of the ropes because
Baron Mordo is is in line to be the
ancient one when the ancient one passes
on so when it appears that dr. strange
is going to become the sorcerer supreme
baron that's when he and Baron Mordo
become enemies gotcha
but dr. strange also has like a whole
you know panoply of enemies that are all
extra-dimensional enemies because as the
sorceress supreme his job is to keep
these extra dimensional threats out so
like Dormammu is probably the one that's
the most no he's a matchstick headed
demon creature who runs the dr. Mazar
dimension okay then he's got his sister
named Umar who's this is her first
appearance dr. strange 1:50 she's just
as bad as Dormammu and just as powerful
there's satanic there's a Shimoga wrath
all of them like very like strong cosmic
entities here's something I've been
wondering about there's so many Avengers
is Doctor Strange and Avenger or has he
been an Avenger how does he fit into the
big picture of the MCU that's a really
tricky one I mean he's a tricky
character to write for because he is so
powerful yeah it's like oh uh you know
like the Chitauri are invading I know
they're not because they're they're sort
of a little afraid of magic in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe why do you
think that is well I think because they
were afraid people wouldn't like on
board the movies when they first started
like superheroes and magic no one can
live at that speed you know like stop
and the the the Infinity stones and
Scarlet Witch and the hand and daredevil
are all sort of starting to like creep
onto that magic universe so I think
Doctor Strange makes sense but I think
they're gonna really nerf him to use the
parlance of our time but they have like
started to do a lot of stuff in the
comics especially Jason Aaron's current
run where they're saying magic has a
cost to it and no matter like anything
that you do yeah there's a cost to you
physically your soul your body something
like that so I can't go probably selling
it with something like so when you drop
some magic it's like oh man
Knapp yeah yeah yeah ah does he have any
experience fighting Thanos or dealing
with Santos or the Infinity Gauntlet
yeah he was an infinity war Infinity
Gauntlet he was like one of the main
guys in those stories yes okay I think
he's the one who helped transport them
to the other side of the universe to
fight Thanos and I think that's what
we're gonna end up seeing where where
we'll see him in the MCU is that he'll
he'll show up in this movie he'll maybe
make an appearance in the infinity war
and then he'll like immediately be
relegated to like advisor status where
the sanctum sanctorum which is his like
magical house in New York is a place
they go for advice where he's willing to
give it but isn't going to get himself
involved in the fray there was talk that
he might have made an appearance in
ant-man but he ended up not well that's
so that's going along with like what
Kevin Feige said at that Marvel event
that they had a couple years ago when
they went into the Microverse and they
broke through that quantum realm that's
where you're starting to dip into like
all these other possible multiverses
Mads Mikkelsen who do we think he's
playing there's been some interesting
theories perhaps the most out-of-the-box
theory is that he is or is some sort of
version of the mindless ones which were
are like these like there's you know
multi dozen be servants of Dormammu who
are basically just rock monsters with
laser eyes that's that's a rough theory
this I have so I think that he's playing
a guy named dr. Charles Benton okay dr.
Charles Benton has only been in a
handful of comics goes on to become this
priest who calls himself
Asmodeus he's like this truly terrifying
demon with like a head right here but
he's also got like a head to mouth right
here
that's like Krang like Krang like uh but
a little bit like Kuato ha ha and you
guys are so excited about this and I
love hearing you talk about it what
draws you to Doctor Strange what is it
about um this particular character is
your favorite character in the Marvel
Universe right this is not intended to
be a pun but like I like how strange he
is yeah he doesn't really fit in the
Marvel Universe except he does um he's
kind of stands apart from everything the
holy Sh we've got a 75-foot demon in New
York I'll take him who else can do what
Doctor Strange there's no one else in
the entire Marvel Universe who can do
and what Doctor Strange doesn't have the
fights that Doctor Strange has and he's
also a redemptive character I think a
lot of geeks can recognize like being
just slightly socially
you know like maladjusted they were
young and then like finding it and
that's dr. strange is like unlikable as
a physician as a surgeon and then finds
through his heroism a way to be like one
of the most charming and we know well
put the other characters in all
sometimes that happens along the way on
the journey you guys have got me so
excited about Doctor Strange are you
excited for Doctor Strange how do you
think he's gonna fit into the MCU let us
know in the comments section below
I want to hear from you matki sax car
thank you for coming out you guys were
great I want to thank you for watching
on how run Nick hit me up on Twitter
bye bye mark if you would give it we're
gonna tattoo spins
Gungans Devon the Duncan Senate if you
thought we could not get worse than the
prequels get ready for Gungan Senate